تحيه طيبه مشاهدينا الكرام الم ياتي
الربيع العراقي الزاحف بقوه على بلاد
الرافدين نتيجه طبيعيه للديكتاتور
الطائفيه البغيضه التي يمارسها طاغيه
العراق نور المالكي واسياده في طهران على
شعب العراق العظيم يصيح معارض
عراقي الم يصبر الشعب العراقي بما فيه
الكفايه على حكم الملال وصبيانهم يضيف
اخر الم يحول المالك عاصمه العراق العظيم
الى واحده من اوسخ مدن
العالم الم يفشل حتى في تنظيف بغداد من
الاو ساخ ناهيك عن تامين ابسط اساسيات
الحياه للشعب من ماء وكهرباء
ودواء اليس طبيعيا ان يثور العراقيون في
وجه حاكم خبرته الوحيده في الحياه كانت
بيع الملابس الداخليه النسائيه والمسابح
وبيع العراق لايران يضيف اخر هل عقر
العراق كي لا يجد غير شخصيه طائفيه بغيضه
تتولى مقاليد الحكم في البلاد الا يخجل
المالك من وصف ثوره العراق العظيمه
بالفقاعي دمشق بعدوى المصطلحات
الرخيصه لكن في المقابل الم ينجز
العراقيون ربيعهم قبل كل العرب عندما
اسقطوا نظام صدام اليس من الخطا ان يثور
الشعب على رئيس حكومه منتخب ديمقراطيا
اليس الحكم في العراق برلمانيا وليس
رئاسيا اليس حريا بثائر ان يضغطوا على م
مثليهم في البرلمان بدل استهداف رئيس
الوزراء لماذا لا ينتظرون حتى موعد
الانتخابات القادمه كما تفعلوا كل
الديمقراطيات الم تتسم بعض الشعارات التي
رفعها المتظاهرون
بالطائف الم تصطف بعض القيادات السنيه
لسنوات الى جانب المالكي وعندما اختلفت
معه راحت تحرض اتباعها عليه اليس المالك
على حق عندما يتهم معارضيه محوله تقسيم
العراق من خلال ثورتهم المزعومه اسئله
اطرحها على الاعلامي العراقي السيد خالد
السراي وعلى الكاتب والاعلاميه العراقيه
السيد هارون محمد نبدا نقاش بعد
الفاصل اهلا بكم مره اخرى مشاهدينا الكرام
نحن معكم في برنامج الاتجاه والمعاكس لو
بدات معك السيد خالد السراي في البدايه
يعني سؤال ساله الكثير من العراقيين
والعرب في واقع الامر على ضوء تصريحات
المالكي وردود افعاله تجاه الربيع العراقي
المتصاعد وصف مئات الالاف من العراقيين
الذين يخرجون الى الشوارع وهذا الربيع
المتصاعد بانه مجرد فقاعه يعني الا يخجل
المالكي من وصف ثوره شعب من وصف الالاف او
مئات الالاف بانهم فقاع البعض يقول وكل
صابونه تنجب فقاعه ومحال ان ينتهي
الصابون ماذا تقول لهم بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم بالتاكيد خلينا نتفق مقدما احنا مو
طرف بانه مجاميع او اعلام يخلق
مسرحيه يحدد الممثلين وبالتالي بالنتيجه
يصدقها احنا ننقل واقع نعيشه انا ما افهم
ربيع انه تتجمع كل اعداء العراق وكانه يا
اعداء العراق اتحدوا اجتمعوا نفاجئ انه
امر قضائي لالقاء قبض تاتي قائمه بقادتها
اللي هم جزء فاعل من الحكومه يعقدون
مؤتمرا صحفيا ليتهم انه الحكومه حكومه
ميليشيات والمالكي قائد ميليشيات وكان هم
جزء من زعامات المليشيات بالعراق نفاجئ
العلم التركي العلم السعودي علم النظام
السابق صور اردوغان علم اقليم كردستان جيش
السوري الحر انا ارد اسال سؤال اي ربيع
عربي الربيع الع العربي على صندوق
الانتخابات اللي يساويني انا ورئيس
جمهوريه كصوت الربيع العربي على التعدديه
السياسيه الربيع العربي على الدستور
العراقي الربيع العربي على حريه الاعلام
يعني هي العمليه لا نقلب الحقائق نستخدم
عباره
سي جميل جدا لكن هذا الكلام هذا الكلام
سمعناه من قبل من القذافي ومن علي عبد
الله صالح ومن مبارك ومن زين العابدين بن
علي ومن بشار الاسد
كلهم وصفوا الثورات على نظام حكمهم او
انظمه حكمهم واحد وصفها بالجرد واححد
وصفها ايضا بشار الاسد بالفقاعات واحد
وصفها بوجبات الكنتاكي وكلهم ذهبوا دقيقه
دقي
دقي وكلهم في نهايه المطاف ذهبوا الى
مزبله الت فلماذا لا يذهب المالكي دقيقه
دقيقه فلماذا لا يذهب المالكي
الكي المالكي نتاج صوت شعب احنا طايت ذب
التاريخ من 2003 هذه انتهينا وعبرنا
المرحله الان حاكيني على بلد ابني تجربه
لماذا كل قرار كل خلاف سياسي كل خلاف
دستوري كل خلاف قانوني راسا يوظف طائفيا
ومناطق ويا دول الجوار المعروفه مواقفها
السيئه من العراق تعالوا ادخلوا دخلوا
العراق اخي الكريم نحن نعاني من مشكله
بالعراق طبعا هي نادره بالشعوب هذا اللي
يرتبط بنظام سابق وتنتهي علاقته بسقوط هذا
النظام نحن يعاني من تركه ان البعض وكانه
بعد ما عنده وطن وغير مسؤول انما مهمته ان
يحرق الوطن لانه نظام ورؤيه وتعسف وسلطه
انتهت جميل جدا سيدي كيف ترد على هذا
الكلام ليس هناك اي يعني اي اسباب تدعو
الى الثوره في العراق وكل ما شاهدناه بس
دقيقه وكل ما شاهدناه في الاونه الاخيره
مجرد مسرحيات اعلاميه رخيصه اذا اذا كان
مئات الالاف
يخرجون ويتظاهرون
ويعتصمون لا يمثلون شيئا فهذا شيء معيب
معيب على من على الحاكم الذي يصف هؤلاء
ب شعارات نتنا
والفقاعه الحاكم الذي لا يحترم شعبه ولا
خيارات شعبه عليه ان ينتظر كل شيء من هذا
الشعب اذا كان الربيع كمصطلح يعني غضبه
شعبيه فما يحدث في العراق غضبه شعبيه اذا
كان الربيع يعني هبه شعبيه فما يحدث في
العراق هبه شعبيه ملايين الناس طلعت في
الانبار وح مليونين نعم في الموصل ملايين
هي حقيقه زين
وانت يقوللك مسرحيات هذا وجهه نظره رايه
انما نحن نقول الحقيقه وعندما يرفع ماذا
يرفع العلم السابق شو شو بالالم السابق شو
ب شنو الظير كلمه الله اكبر يعني ها
الكلمه لازم يقول الخميني اكبر مثلا يعني
مثلا طيب هناك اعلام ايرانيه في شارع
بغداد في ميادين بغداد لماذا لا يتم
الاعتراض عليها يقولون بعض صورتين هي
الرفعت وبعد
ذلك
حجبت هناك جداريات للخميني في بغداد
وكربلاء والنجف جداريات وليست صور لماذا
لا يعترضون عليها بعدين اللي رفع هذا منو
الشعب هذا سواء كان بعثيا او غير بعثيا
هذا مو شعب مو من حقه يعبر عن رايه مو من
حقه ان يقول الدستور يقول من حق الناس ان
يعبروا عن رايهم ما دامت التظاهر سلميه
ارفع اي شعار انتشاء نعم ماكو اشكال
ولكن هذا يدلل على حقد دفين في نفس نوري
المالكي الاماره بالسوء دائما لكن يقوللك
الرجل نوري المالكي يختلف عن بقيه
الطواغيت الرجل منتخب وجاء عبر صناديق الا
منتخب في مناطق السنه العرب ومحافظاتهم لم
يستطع واحد من مرشحي نور المارك نفوز اذا
هذا يعني ان لا يمثل الا جماعته واضح خلي
واحد نائب واحد ما فاز في كل المحافظات
السنيه وعلى هذا الاساس يجب ان يعطي للناس
في هذه المناطق حريتهم في التعبير خصوصا
هم ما هم بده يسوون انقلاب بده يسوون ثوره
من حقه ان يرفع مطاليب شعبيه وهذه
المطاليب لا تهم لا فئه واحده لا منطقه
واحده لا محافظه واحده هي مطاليب شعبيه
ذات طابع انساني طيب رئيس الحكومه عندما
لا يستجيب لهذه المطاليب الشعبيه العامه
وليست الخاصه ماذا يعني هذا اليست هذه
دكتاتوريه اليس هذا ظلم على فئات من الناس
ماذا تريد طيب تريد اطلاق سراح المعتقلين
ما بها شيء اطلاق سراح الافراج عن النساء
المعتقلات
ظلما وعدوانا ام المغتصبات والمغتصب ويتم
اغتصابهن في المعتقلات في السجون وهناك
حالات كشف عنها المدعي العام وهذا وظيفه
رسميه اغتصاب حرائر العراق ماجدات العراق
جميل جدا هي حقيقه ولذلك على نور المالكي
ان يفهم ان هذه المرحله اذا كانت تظاهرات
سلميه اذا لم يستجب لها وهي مطاليب شعبيه
عامه فانها
ستتحول الى شيء اخر اذا كان حكيما
ومنتبه
وعاقلا عليه ان يتوقف
و يستوعب مو يستوعب يستجيب شنو يستوعب
غصبا عليه هي مسائل لا تهم اهل الانبار
ولا اهل الموصل هي قضايا عراقيه جميل جدا
سمعت هذا الكلم سيد سمعت هذا الكلام كيف
ترد لا اريد ان ان اكرر نعم نعم طيب هذه
مطالب يعني لماذا تسميها طيب انا بدي
اسالك مش انتم ديمقراطيين يقول لك الرجل
بالتاكد طيب
تفضل كل مطالب الدستور العراقي يضمن كل
المطالب المشروعه ويوفر لها غطاء قانوني
نعم العمليه من تخرج من اطارها الدستور
والقانون كيف تتعامل وياها اعطني بلد
بالعالم يقبل ان ترفع اعلام كل الاطراف
المعاديه لها ها وحده طيب طيب بس دقيقه
الاعلام خليك دقيقه طيب يا سيدي الاعلام
لماذا حرام يرفع العلم العراقي السابق اه
وبعض الاعلام العربيه الاخوه والاشقاء
وحلال ان ترفع صور الخامنئي وخمن وخامس
وما بس
بع هذ
اولا انا اسال سؤال خلي الجزيره تتحمل
وانا كفيل وبغداد واخذ راح ارجع الشعبي
واط انطيني جداريه موجوده اخي الكريم احنا
ما علينا بالت انت حكيني هسه على موضوعنا
نحكي به جداريه غير موجوده بغداد كربلاء
اكو قضيه عار على اي واحد يستخدم شرف
المراه العراقيه تدري انت الان معتقلات را
يطلع شنو هذا المغتصبات او لا شواجه
عوائلهن اعطني اسم وحده خل ينطيني اسم
وحده اغتصبت هذا منطق تشويه السمعه بهذا
الشكل احنا ما عندنا المجتمع العراقي ولا
نتقبل الكلام عن
المغص تقرير المدع العام تقرير المدع
العام رسم مدع العام نعم الى محث الم رئيس
القضاء مجلس القضا يقول ا
من سئلوا اعطنا اسما واحدا شكلت لجنه
حكماء من الطائفه السنيه
الكريمه عليه
هذا حكماء عيب هذا يمثل الحكماء لا لا
الناس بس سيدي خليك شويه بدي ارجعلك عليها
ص عندنا بالعراق هسه تعلم اللي ما يمتلك
ذره ضمير واحترام لشرف النساء الان كل
امراه معتقله صورها مختصبه لانه ماكو
تسميه ولاك معروفه خل اكملك المطيب
المشروعه المط دقيقه خليني على النساء على
النساء اذا كل الكلام عن وجود مغتصبات
وحرائر وما جادات العراق كلام فار ما موجو
خليك ش خليك دقيقه هذا الكلام هذا الكلام
مفبرك اخي تقرير المدعي العام المرفوع الى
ر مجلس القضاء الاعلى شنو عرض عرض ار من ع
مين اللي يغتصب النساء
الحرام ستقام دعوه على القناه اللي نشرت
وستقام دعاوه قضائيه على كل من
الادعاء عام رسمي رسمي مطف رسمي مسؤول
واسمه وكذا كاظم الطائي زين هذا يعني ان
هناك محاولات بعد ان ثبت باليقين والادله
والثبوت وتقرير المدعي العام هاي اكو
مساله مو اعلام هذا مو مقال ولا خبر هذا
تقرير المدع العام المرفوع الى مدحت محمود
رئيس مجلس القضاء يقول في اربع نساء
معتقلات من عدد 10 اخت صبنا جميل جدا طيب
انا الصميدعي رئيس اللجنه القضائيه
للحكماء واسميهم حكماء لانه اختيارهم معهم
لجنه قضائيه كل النساء اللي اتهم الان
سيقيم قضائيه اخي الكريم لانه انت تخيل
لنفرض ه 100 امراه من هي الاختصب تسميه
يعني كل امراه راح تطلع
بالعراقيه بس دقيقه بس بدون مقاطعه بس
خليني اس البعض يقول في واقع الامر ان
النظام العراقي بقياده المالكه ليس متهما
فقط باغتصاب الحرائر والجدات بل باغتصاب
الرجال في السجون هذ اقوللك هي المشكله
انه انتم بالنظام العربي الرسمي ما
متعودين على اعلام منفتح احنا علام منفل
يصيغ ما يصيغ كما يشاء وبالتالي التجربه
العراقيه مت المطاليب المشروعه المطاليب
المشروعه اول من بادر للاستجابه دوله رئيس
الوزراء المطاليب المشروعه تناقش وشكلت
لجنه وفعلا اطلق سراح عشر 10ش سجينه على
اعتبار انه ولا تزر وز وزراء اخرى وحاسب
الجهات الامنيه انا اسال بالله عليكم بخلط
الاوراق من انه انت الان اي اجرا تاخذ
الايقاف الارهاب انت طائفي انت مستهدف
طائفه انت مستهدف محافظات اكو صلاحيات
عندنا بالدستور العراقي فصل بين السلطات
صلاحيات برلمانيه وصلاحيات يعني للبرلمان
وسلطه التنفيذيه لماذا يحمل المالكي كل
شيء لماذا يقبل لنفسه رئيس النواب مجلس
النواب العراقي يقف قلب البيانات ويقف خلف
المتظاهرين ويقول على رئيس الوزراء وانت
صلاحيتك الهروب من المسؤوليه طيب رميها
على اكتاف هذا الرجل لمصلحه من خلط الاوق
خليك خليك نقطه اريد جوابا سريعا على هذه
النقطه طيب لماذا طيب دقيقه ن بس دقيقه
يوم الاحد دعا الى جلسه طارئه لمناقشه اكو
ازمه بالبلد كم حضرها 150 من اصل 300 وشوي
كتله رئيس الوزراء لا تحضر وحلفائها حتى
لا يكون نصاب حتى لا تكون
محاسبه
لاحظ كيف يتصرف نوري المالكي ام يريد ان
يسيطر على البرلمان وهو قد سيطر على
الهيئات المستقله بالكامل اصبح طاغيه يعني
هو هو لا يصلح ان يكون طاغيه لان حتى
الطاغيه ايضا له مواصفات ها هذا نتاج
حزب بس دقيقه حزب طائفي هذا هذا لا يستطيع
ان يتعامل بالسياسه الطاغي ايضا يتعامل
بالسياسه هذا ما له علاقه هذا مكاري احنا
نسميه لذلك الان عندما
يقول البرلمان شنو البرلمان من مجموعه
كتل الان
نلاحظ الكتله الكرديه ضده افتعل معهم
مشاكل زين ولا هم انقس مننا افتعل مع
السنه العرب اللي هم هو يسميهم المكون
القائمه العراقيه تمثل المكون السني نصف
المكونات الشيعيه التيار الصدري والمجلس
بالبرلمان اذا هذا غير سق
جم اين هي شرعيه نور المالك اين شرعيتك
كرئيس حكومه جم ج اذا الكتل بما فيها كتله
الكتل الشيعيه ضده طيب وقف شوي عن النقطه
لكن عندما يلجا الى اساليب الاغراء
والرشوه والافساد
هذه الان من من من اصطفى معه في عدم
الحضور الى جلسه هادي العامري منظمه بدر
كيف لانه جاء برئيس منظمه بدر وعينه وزيرا
وهاي الوزاره وزاره النقل اكبر وزاره
للحراميه اكبر وزاره لانها وزاره
كبيره اولا المالكي عين
وزراء سهله جدا هسه اخلط لك الاوراق كلها
هو المالكي عين وزراء هو المالك اختار
وزراء لو الكتل اختارت وزراءها وفرضها
عليه فرضا بالت بدون م الوضع بالعراق اخي
الكريم شخصنه الخلاف مع المالكي مو لانه
الخلاف مع المالكي المطلوب راس العراق ها
م من لكن شخصن مع المالكي اولا لطبيعه
مواصفات هذا الرجل وموقف النزيه تجاه
مصالح شعبه وثانيا اخفاء الاهداف الحقيقيه
الهدف الحقيقي التعدديه بالعراق النظام
السياسي الجديد بالعراق المعادله السياسيه
غير مقبوله مرفوضه يجب ان يعود العراق الى
نظام التمييز يجب ان يعود العراق الى
نظام نظام
بس خليك خليك وقف شوي خليك وقف شوي خليك
وقف شوي لا لا وقف بس انا بدي اجيك بس
دقيقه يا سيدي لا بدون مقاط سيد خالد سيد
خالد النظام السابق النظام
السابق مجرم على الكل
هو الشيعه هذا مو طائفي حزب الدعوه مو
طائفي طائفي
وعميل انا اقوللك الطائفيه والاله
الطائفيه سي الكريم بس اسال سؤال بس اسال
سؤال رئيس الجمهوريه سني رئيس سني كردي هو
ما يقول ه صارو التعبيه ايش عندنا
بالمناطق الغربيه شنو التعبيه ما عندنا
خلاف مع الاكراد لان يربطنا المذهب هذه
ايتام النظام السابق ايتام النظام
السابق هو يعرف كل ز ما يسمى المناطق
اللينا عليها بين الكراد ومحافظات الع
السه بس دقيقه بس دقيقه سيدي بس خليني بس
دقيقه في هذه النقطه بدون مقاطعه رجاء
بدون مقاط
[موسيقى]
مشكله الاكراد
قيه
الاره محافظات سنه العرب الموصل وصلاح
الدين و بس خليني خليني خليني اسال بس
خليني خليني خليني اجي للنقطه خليني اجي
للنقطه انت تقول المطلوب راس العراق
والنظام السياسي والنزاهه والدنيا خلينا
ناخذ هذه النقطه الكثيرون يقولون ان يعني
المالكي يعمل بمبدا متني بدائها وانسلت
كيف يتهم هذه الثوره وهذا الحراك الكبير
بانه حراك طائفي نتن طيب هل هذا الحراك هو
النتن والطائفي ام الطائفي الذي يبيع بلد
باكمله هو العراق العظيم لمل لي طهران على
اساس طائفي الطائفي دقيقه بس دقيقه بس
دقيقه والطائفي والطائفي الطائفي هو ايران
التي اعتبرت ثوره العراق دقه في الاطعم
تطابقت في الاوصاف ايران الطائفيه التي
اعتبرت ثوره العراق طائفيه وسوريا طائفيه
لان تريد النظامين العلوي والشيعي اما
ثوره البحرين صارت ديمقراطيه ما شاء الله
وهي اكبر وهي اكبر وهي عباره عن فقاعه
طائفيه حقيقيه كما يقول 70% قوا هذول ما
لهم حق هذول خار النظام الرسم العربي
النظام الرسم العربي ما يقبل 70% بحارنا
شيعه شيعه يروحوا لايران يعني تك ايران
يعني
ايه يعني معنا العراق فارسي هذه الجريمه
المزايده
المزي خجي نتفق طائفه لا يوجد اي فرق
وانما اصحاب الفضل والثقل بالعراق موجودين
ثقافيا تاريخيا سنه العراق انا الان ما
جاي انطق باسم طائفه وكرام موجود موقفهم
وهم من كسر ظهر الارهاب وهم من طرد
القاعده وهم من شكله الصحوات وهم من اطفوا
على عمليه السياسيه لاستقرار هذه لا نفرق
عليها المشكله مع زعامات سياسيه الزعامات
السياسيه اولا انا اسال سؤال باي بلد
بالعالم هسه من تقولون انتم تقولون
تظاهرات ما يريدون يصفونها يعني فشكل
سياسي او طائفي بالله عليك اكو شخص
بالبرلمان يجر ان يلفظ قذره على ملايين
العراقيين شميل تحت اي بابم مذوبه مكذوبه
كبيره والتلفزيون موجود والصوره
موجوده لم
ترد س وقفلي عندك شوي وقف شوي انا بدي
اسالك لا بدي اسالك الرجل يقوللك الرجل
يقول لك انتم تركزون كثيرا بانه هذه
الثوره او ما تم تسمونها ثوره عراقيه تريد
احقاق الحق واعاده الدوله او تخليص الدوله
من طائفيته مش هيك تقولون الرجل يقول لك
هذا الكلام غير صحيح المشكله ليست طائفيه
ثانيا لماذا يرفع المتظاهرون شعارات
طائفيه هل هذا يفيد العراق او يقسم العراق
بس دقيقه دقيقه والامر الاخر الامر الاخر
بالله هل يعقل انت تعلم الهاشمي
والعيسوي كانوا سبن على عسل مع المالكي
عندما كانت مصالحهم متفقه الان عندما
اختلفت مصالح الهاشمي واليساوي مع مع
المالكي اصبح طائفيا لماذا لماذا
تريد الذي يحدث الان اكبر من الهاشمي
واكبر من
العيساوي هذه هبه شعب اخي اي اي عيساوي اي
هاشمي عندما تخرج ملايين الناس تطالب
وترفع وتهتف الطائفيه كل مطالب المشروع
على راس وع العين واول من قب رئس وزراء
لكن اسقاط
النظام كانت كان مقب اسقاط النظام قبل ما
تقدر ترفع
عينك الان ب نشت و نسب وع
حريه حريه راي القانون يكفلها انت تكون
ض بدون مقاطعه اارج يطالبون باسقاط
الحكومه بترحيل الحكومه باسقاط
هذا هذا من ح بس هم يسقطون النظام وليس
الحكومه حقهم ايضا المطالبه بقط هذول شعب
جايين من الفلبين يوم من السنغال مو
عراقيين لماذا لا يطالب لماذا لا يعبر عن
رايه هو عنده موقف من نوري المالكي انا
ايضا كمواطن حظ نستقي طيب خلينا على موضوع
الطائفيه كيف طائفيه اولا
شوف قال ان النظام السابق كان يفرس العجم
للعلم وهذ جلال طلباني قالها بعضب لسانه
السجلات اخذوها بعد الاحتلال مال حزب
البعث تبين ان هناك
65% من قيادات وكوادر حزب حزب البعث شيعيه
من اصول شيعيه وللعلم حتى يعرف الاخ الان
نوري
المالكي ابن عمه ابن عم الله ضياء يحيى
العلي كان امين سر فرع ومحافظه كريت لاحظ
هذا النظام الذين يقولون عليه انه طائفي
طيب خلينا نرجع الان ما هو ما هو الوجه
الط كان يحمي نور الماركي من التوقيفات هو
الوجه الطائفي الذي
يريد
مجون ماشي على رصيف محفر شرط جابني
بس ما هو الوجه الطائفي الذي يريد ان
يتخلص منه العراق عراقيون اين هو الرجل
يقوللك هذا غير موجود احنا نحكي كلام ولا
بالتجربه انطيك هديه من
عنديل ليست هناك طائفيه عندما شخص واحد
شخص شخص واحد رئيس وزراء قائد عام قوات
المسلحه وزير ثلاث وزارات الدفاع
والداخليه والامن الوطني والمشرف على 12
جهاز ام ام ام تاتي الى الجيش 17 فرقه به
ام 17 فرقه اها
15 قائد فرقه
شيعي واحد كردي والسني المحسوب على السنه
وهو متشيع يعني معروف ناصر الغنام ومعلن
هو الرجل اي انه انا شيعي وكيل قائد تجي
على محافظه كل الاحصاءات الرسميه تقول ان
السنه العرب فيها
75 الى 80% محافظه دياله فيها 21 موقع
قيادي اداري عسكري امني مين شيعي كلهم
شيعه
21 20 شيعي وواحد
كردي فقبل فتره احد احد الاشخاص يقول ل
نور الم هي دوله الطائفه اذا بدي احكي لك
هي محافظه سنيه الاغلبيه السكانيه سنيه
شلون الناصريه اغلبيه سكانيه شيعيه
اع ولا سني طيب واحد من وجهاء دياله يقول
لنوري الماركي ما يصير قال مو المحافظ سني
طيب المحافظ مو انت تعينه ها مجلس
المحافظه يجتمع وينتخب عضوا من اضائه زين
قائد الفرقه العسكريه قائد العمليات قائد
الشرطه مع مدير الاستخبارات مدير الجنائيه
شو زين هي مو طائفيه محافظه ذات اغلبيه
سنيه عرب
كل القيادات فيها الريم جميل طب انا بدي
اسالك من اتجاه الاخر طيب هذا الكلام
الرجل لا يتجنى ياتيك بالارقام كم عددهم
كيف يسيطر الشيعه وانه هذه هذا الحراك في
العراق الان هو حراك لتصحيح وضع لاعاده
الامور الى نصابها البعض يقول انه ايران
الان تغلغلت في الجيش العراقي تغلغلت في
المخابرات العراقيه تغلغلت في اداره النفط
الا يعني هم يسيطرون على كل شيء
الان ايران هناك من يقول ايضا بان ثوره
العراق هي سند لثوره سوريا لان الثورتين
تواجهان عدوا واحدا الا وهو ايران الطائفي
الشيعي الذي يريد ان يشيع المنطقه ويقضي
على المنطقه هذا هكذا يقولون مساله النظام
الرسمي العربي يخلي ايران العدو رقم واحد
بالمنطقه متروك ما علينا ها مو موضوعنا ها
محاوله رهن اراده عراقين وكانه احنا بيادق
شطرنج تحت اراده ايرانيه هذا ظلم ل
عروبتنا ظلما ظلم ظلم الطائفه بياد اطلاقا
شو
بيادق البيدق البيدق سيدي الكريم اللي
يرفع على من يقتل شعبه البيتك اللي يصير
دليل خسيس يجيب الارهاب يدلي على اي مكان
يذ به العراقيين البيتك الرخيص انا ارجع
وياك على قضيه مهمه جدا ما الذي يجري في
العراق هي هي حرب طائفيه هي اجتماعيه
اطلاقا اطلاقا ذاك العراقي الشيعي وذاك
العراقي السني وكليتنا يهمنا ان نتعايش
ووطنا ومشتركين به
الحرب توظيف سياسي طبعا يستغل الدين يخليه
غطاء القتل والارهاب انتهينا منها كل
اجراء وكل خلاف انت ايش عندك وسيله غير
تستنتج بدول معاديه لتجربه العراقيه وان
تلبسه لباس طائفي ولباس مناطقي اعطني حدث
بسيط انا سؤال اذا الغي يعني المسائله
وعداله الغي مكافحه الارهاب سؤال واحد اكو
بلد بالعالم يتعرض لارهاب ماكو منظومه
قانونيه تحميه واذا لغينا مكافحه الارهاب
ليش انتم يا ابن جيفي وربعك كل واحد عنده
افواج حمايات المن ضد من ضد من هذا السؤال
زين اسالك سؤال صحوات بالانبار منو قتلهم
الان يقول الاخ المنظومه العسكريه الشيعيه
14000 بالتقسيمه 14000 شرطي استحقاق
الانبار استثناء انطاه
28400 وكل من ابناء الانبار لحمايه
الانبار منو دعم الصحوات منو قال للسن
تعالوا
وقف شويه وقف شوي وقف شوي انا بدي اسالك
لا لا لا بس اجب عل عندي سؤال عندي سؤال
باختصار باختصار تفضل مكافحه الارهاب انه
ضروره طيب ضروره يجب ان قانون الارهاب يعم
على الجميع بس بديك هناك نقطه هناك نقطه
لماذا اربع ارهاب ه الماده التي المخ اكو
حكومه تحترم نفسها اكو رئيس حكومه يحترم
نفسها
المستور المخبر المخبر السيري بالدستور بس
بس ك نذهب بعيدا خليني ارجع لنقطه مهمه
يقول لك الرجل من المعيب ان تتهم قياده
العراق بانها مجرد بيادق في ايدي الفرس
هذه الاعيب رخيصه كفاكم متاجره بالخطر
الايراني والخطر الشيعي اول شيء واحده من
اسباب غضبه نوري المالكي على تظاهرات
الانبار قف ما تعروف لانهم قطعوا
الامدادات التي كانت تتب من العراق الى
سوريا ومن ايران الى سوريا حقائق زين ولا
شو يعني كثيره من التظاهرات التي خرجت في
البصره على سبيل المثال لماذا لم يقل
عليها فقاع لماذا لم يقل عليها نتنا مثلا
مو لانها وقفت في و في وجه المعونات
للنظام السور خطا للغطاء الدستور لظاهر
الغطاء القانوني للتظاهر مساله الارهاب من
حقك ارهاب هي اربعه ارهاب ارجعلي ارجعلي
على نقطه الانبار كيف يعني كيف س
وماذا تنكر تنكر
بشار الاسد تنكر واحد ها حقائق ين يعني
تريد ان تقول الثوره تريد ان تقول الثوره
العراقيه سند للثوره السوريه نحن امتداد
يعرف
زفر عن را العراق هذا مشروع تسيق العراق
وسوريا
هو
شج العرايه
العص عيب واحد يقول تجربه
عيبان الشعب مرتخ برلمان
دائم انت مو يساري كت انت يساري
كعكس
عندكي
المجعلي الى موضوع ايران ارجعي يا سيدي
ارجع لي الى موضوع انه تقول انه هذه الهبه
وهذه الثوره تريد ان تحرر العراق من الخطر
الايراني ومن الرجس الايراني من الوسخ
الايراني اثبتت التجربه بما لا يقبل الشك
ان ايران تعمل بعد ادركت انها ستخسر
الساحتين السوريه واللبنانيه تعوض الخساره
وين تعوضها في العراق في العراق الان اكو
فتره صار ام اكو استهداف لمحافظه الانبار
بالذات بالذات من من من الحكومه طيب لماذا
المعتقلين الحكومه تقول 40,000 ل لنفترض
ان هذا الرقم صحي نعم نعم انا اسال الاخ
ليستفسر
39000 من محافظه الاعم ام وبعض المعتقلين
كانت القوات الامريكيه قد اعتقلتهم ماذا
تريد ان تقول تعاون اكو الشيء الذي نريد
ان نقوله ان ايران تريد ان تخترق
المحافظات السنيه وخاصه محافظتي الانبار
والموصل ليكون الطريق سالكا الى نحو سوريا
ولذلك هذه التظاهرات الان تظاهرات سلميه
نقولها بصراحه واذا لم يست قادتها انت
قادتها خل نفهم لانه سا عزه الدور ركب
الموجه ساعه النقشبندي من قائده خ عامه
لديها لديها قيادات معروفه
تريد تريد ان تقول لي ان تريد ان تقول لي
ان الجيش العراقي الحر في طريقه الى
بالتاكيد اذا لم يستجب الى المطاليب
الشعبيه
السلميه طبعا ماذا ماذا تريد من الناس
تغتصب نساؤهم يعتقل شبابهم يختى رجالهم
تحكمهم ايران يابا ليش ليش ما يسوي ثوره
لا يسوي ثوره والثوره كيف تصير بالسلاح
طبعا لذلك عندما نقول على نوري المالكي ان
يستجيب لهذه المطالب الشعبيه ذات الطابع
الانساني عليه عليه ان يحذر لان غدا لا
تعرف ماذا سيحمل دقيقه وده بس انا اسالك
انت لماذا مثل ما سالت بدي اسالك سيد خالد
بس اسمع لي طيب انت لماذا لماذا تحاول ان
تقلل من اهميه ان هذا الحراك ان هذا
الحراك
موجه ضد العدو الاول للعراق الان الا وهو
ملالي طهران يقولون يا اخي انا بدي اسالك
نعم البعض يقول حتى شيعه العراق ضاقوا
ذرعا بالتدخل الايراني الصفيني في شؤون
العراق مش كلامي كلامه انا شو لي علاقه
يعني شو شو اليس حريا بالعراقيين ان
يطالبوا بتنظيف العراق الايرانيين لم
يبقوا شيئا في العراق الا وسيطروا عليه
وال الايرانيون الان يخافون من ثوره
العراق لانها امتداد لثوره سوريا الموصل
والانبار الى سوريا هذه هي القصه كيف تفسر
ذلك اخي الكريم شوف هذه هذه الملاحظه ارجع
واقول لك انا النظام الرسمي العربي اللي
يصور ايران العدو اللدود هذه متروكه الى
محاسبه التاريخ اذا فعلا او لا انا ما
عندي هالمشكله تفرضها علي انت ليش تفرض
علي فشي وكانه حقيقه وما موجود
طيب ومئات الالاف اللي موجوده تقول تسقط
ايران في العراق جيد اسممع لي جيد اكو
خلاف اكو صراع سياسي اكو توظيف المشكله
اكو مطالب مشروعه مثل ما قال الاستاذ صارت
بالبصره وصارت بالنجف وصارت بكربلا وصارت
بدي الصدر ماكو اشكال وصارت بالانبار
وصارت بنينوى سابقا شنو الاشكال لكن هل
معقوله مصير شعب عراقي وتضحياته تصير
رهينه نساوم نبته سياسيا على مجموعه توظف
كل شي لاجل تدميه التجربه العراقيه
والعوده الوراء لتقسيم العراق شوف ها
النغمه مال الترابط تقسيم
العراق يقسم العراق الذي يثور من اجل
احقاق الحق او الذي يحول العراق الى طائفه
الى طائفه الذي يحول الدول الى طائفه الذي
يحول الدوله الى طائفه انا بدي احكيلك على
الغطاء السياسي اللي يحاول يتبناها شنو
علاقه الظاهرين نظام انت جزء منه انته
وراح المزبله التاريخ وخلصنا منه انت شنو
تتمنى التظاهرات شنو علاقه الجيش السوري
الحر شنو علاقه علم السعوديه شنو علاقه
علم اردوغان هذ اللعب شنو هذول شو علاقه
علم خم هؤلاء ليسوا المتظاهرين حلط حلال
يعني غلط ويمزق ويمزق وين تحه الارجل كمان
كما يقول العراق يمزق اي علم خارج دقيقه
هل انت بس دقيقه هل انت مع دوس العلم
العراقي في الاير العلم الايراني في
العراق دوسوا
بالصرامة عايش خارج العراق واغرد باتجاهات
سياسيه معينه انا بدي احكي لك هاي اللي
عايشينه لا مشكله مع متظاهر الانبار جميل
قضيه مو سياسيه مو طائفيه اطلاقا ما عندنا
صح طائفي طيب ماشي ماشي خل اخدمك نحن نعلم
ولا يمكن لنا ان ننكر الارهاب اللي كان
يفجر 20 سياره يوميا فقط في بغداد كسره
وظهره الانبار جميل وطردوه خارج ال
ويطردون هؤلاء طيب ماشي لما لما مطاليب
شعبيه مشروعه تيجي تتبناها تصعد فوق
جميل خليني اسالك رائع طيب لنترك الطائفيه
على جن فقط هو اكثر من مره اخونا هاجم
النظام العربي الرسمي انه هو ه ج انا فقط
اسئله هو النظام العربي الرسمي مو ساهم
باسقاط النظام السابق منين الجيوش والقوات
الامريكيه
الطلق
بعراق جابوا نور المارك نور زين جابوا هال
النماذج البائسه تحكم العراق
بس ارجعلك انا
ارجك لكن مهما يكون انا هذا رئيس ورائي
وافهم وطنيته وافهم شعبيته وافهم قيمته
وجوده ب الفتره اللحظه و الشعوب الح
باللحظات الحرجه تفر قاده
تاريخيه المجموع يتقدم على الفر خليني
اسالك نتحول الى محور اخر البعض يقول لو
تركنا الطائفيه جانبا الا وهي من اهم
مطالب المحتجين وتركنا ايضا موضوع ال
السجون وكيف يغتصب الرجال والنساء كما
يدعون احن ما لنا علاقه طيب لماذا لا ناخذ
انه العراق الان بالرغم من انه يمتلك
واحده من اكبر الميزانيات في العالم
العربي ويعوم على محيط من النفط هل يعقل
ان الشعب العراقي يشرب مياه مسرطنه هل
يعقل ان الشعب العراقي لا يجد البنزين
الذي بلاده مليانه بالبنزين طيب هل يعقل
ان لا يجد الكهرباء الكهرباء لا تاتي الى
العراق
الا سؤال بالحلقه هذا تفضل اهم سؤال
بالحلقه هذ اخي الكريم اذا اكو تهميش
للسنه فمم فيليه المسؤولين عن تهميشهم اذا
تهميش للشيعه ممثلين ومسؤولين عن تهميشهم
اخي الكريم الان ما الذي كسبه الشيعه خاطر
نقول السنه مظلومين ما عندنا احنا حتى لو
اكو نواقص بالكهرباء فهي مظلوميه عامه
الانبار ك البصره ان لم تكن البصره اتعس
المشكله وين تك مسؤوليه الملكي في كل هذا
الخراب هذا السؤال هذا السؤال كم هم وزراء
العراق هذا المصيبه الجريمه عند ما تطلع
انت وزير وزاره سياديه وخلفك رئيس
البرلمان وعلى يمينك نائب رئيس الوزراء
وتقول و حكومه ميليشيات ليش باقين بها
وليش مصرين على استلام وزارات سياديه وليش
اي اسمح لي اذا هذه المساله انه انت احسب
لك الوزارات هسه واحسب لك وزارات التحالف
الكردستاني واحسب لك وزارات التيار الصدري
و وزارات دوله القانون الخدمات اذا ما
الوزير حاسبه ليش في العراق تخلط الاوراق
ويحمل شخص
ليش الميزانيه
العيسا اكمل العيساوي وزير ماليه لو لا
خلي يجي العيساوي يقول انا منط الابار فرض
عل المالكي ماط حصه
لبار هذا مو منطق خلط الاوراق جميل جميل
طيب سؤال دقيقه بس انا بدي اسالك
مثل ي بس دقيقه انا بدي اسالك يا اخي ب
اسك سيدي الرجل يقول لك طيب موافق معك على
انه هناك ازمه كبيره ازمه معيشه في العراق
ازمه اجتماعيه كبيره ازمه مياه ازمه
كهرباء ازمه فساد ازمه كذا لكن السؤال
المطروح لماذا تضعون كل اللوم وكل الحق
على هذا الشخص اللي اسمه نوري المالكي بدي
اسالك الصدر يهاجم المالكي اليس لدى الصدر
ست وزراء لماذا لا يفعلون شيئا من اجل
الارتقاء بالعراق اجتماعيا ومعيشي دقيقه
لماذا تضعون اللوم على شخص وتتركون هذه
المحاصصات القميئ الطائفيه القميئ الهاشمي
ليش ما دار باله على سنه العراق الا بعد
ما تزاعل مع المالكي بالله هي مساله خصه
احنا نتحدث بشان عام الشان العام لا ينصرف
الى الاشخاص
في العرف في كل الدول التي تحترم نفسها
طبعا عاده رئيس الحكومه هو مسؤول عن كل
الوزارات ومسؤول عن توجيه كل الوزراء ا
الوزير الفاشل يستطيع ان غني عنه لكنه
مربوط
بالمحاصصة للازمات ازمه بعد ازمه لا
يستطيع ان يعيش بدون ازمه وخر يبد ان
الازمات زي ما عنده ما عنده منهج حزب
الدعوه ما عنده منهج حزب الدعوه اقرا
ادبيات اقرا تراثه ما عنده منهج سياسي
اقتصادي اجتماعي فلذلك يفتعل الازمه شوف
خلال خلال شهر كم ازمه ما البلد لا يتحمل
ازماتها سياسيه ازمه م صفقه الاسلحه
والفساد الليبي ازمه مال البنك المركزي
وال التلاعب الفضيع الليبي ازمه مع هذا
يسمون اقليم كردستان الان ازمه مع السنه
العرب شو هي شنو ه شنو هك وقف لي شوي وقف
لي شوي بس وقفلي سييد خالد انا بدي اسالك
طيب هذا السؤال يقودنا او هذا الكلام
يقودنا الى ما يطرحه العراقيون الان يقول
لك من الطبيعي ان يكون كل هذا الفساد وكل
هذه المشاكل وكل هذا الترهل في العراق لان
خبره رئيس الوزراء على مدى خبرته الوحيده
في الحياه انه كان يبيع ملابس نسائيه
ومسابح يا اخي هذا ه يقول الع هذا شرف
اللهه شرف اللهه انه باع كل شيء وما رمى
نفسه باجهزه المخابرات وما صار عم شو
الفنادق خمس نجوم ما كان يشتغل مع
المخابرات السوريه كان عاش ملك اطلاقا كان
عايش ملك زمانه اذا الان يعتبرون عار على
مناضل انه يطلع قوت يومه ويناضل ما علينا
اولا المالكي رئيس مجلس الوزراء ثم اثير
سؤال واطالب الاستاذ يجاوبني عليه المالكي
يفتح الازمات والمالكي متمسك بالسلطه
والمالكي فاسد ده يطلب انتخابات مبكره ليش
تخب انتخابات مبكره بده يطلب منكم
انتخابات مكرهك را الشعب اولا اسمح لي
استاذنا اسمح لي اسمح لي استاذنا الدستور
مو يقول المواطن الشعب مصدر السلطات يعود
الصندوق للمواطنين يا اخي غلطنا انتخبنا
غلط رجعونا خلي نشوف المالك يطالب الان
ليش ترفون تخافون اكو دستور يقول انطيني
من ليش ما ارشح اني مثلا مشمول بقانون ليش
المالك الان تستقيل حكومتك وما ترشح يلا
نسوي
انتخابات مو
هزيمه
مغالطه فقط اريد ه النقطه يريد انتخابات
مبكره هو يشرف عليها لا ماضيه مستقله كل
الكتل شاركت بها استاذ مؤقته
مؤقته
المفوضيه خلكم
خل رئي لومه اذا كان يجيب نائب والله
العظيم الامريكان سوا الانتخابات في
الاردن والله العظيم اللي خسر بالانتخابات
الماضيه المالكيه والله العظيم سؤال
الفساد الف هو دور الف ما هو دور الفساد
ما هو دور بجملتين ما هو دور الفساد في
هذا الربيع العراقي المتصاعد هذه حكومه
منخوره من راسها حتى قاعها ورئيسها حرامي
ق للنظام
استاذ النواب الشيعه مو مو سنه حتى لا
يقولون انه دول سنه صباح
الساعدي حتى طلع مكتب الماركي يسرق مكتبه
موظفين ناهيك عن صفقه السلاح الكبيره مع
مع الروس شنو مع الروس روس الدينار ما
مدفوع ليش تبر تخلقون
اوهاي عيش عليها عيش عليه مطره مطره واحده
اغرقت بغداد بغداد اللي عمرها ما غرقت من
54 مطره مطره واحده وانا اتفق مع الشيخ
صباح الساعدي عندما قال عن نوري المالكي
بطل المجاري بطل المجاري القذره طبعا لان
اكو مجاري ماصاب اولا اولا ماما يكون
انسان ارجوك رجال رئيس وزراء العراق ارجوك
رجال ملعون ابو العقل النظام السابق اظون
بالعقل القديم ماكم علاقه بكم ما تحترمون
اي
شيون
س مثل عض البرلمان يقول اولاد الكذا
واولاد المتعه ه المنطق
هاكم كانق ادخليا انتخابات ادخل جيبوا حزب
الب
مكم عراقي حزب البعث شن منين جاب حزب البث
عراقي
اجرم
سؤ
واح سؤال واحد سؤ واح
سؤال
خالب 5 ملا ع اخر سالر سؤال اخر سؤال اخر
سؤال بجمله واحده اخر سؤال بجمله واحده
البعض يقول الان البعض العرب وبعض
العراقيين على الثوره العراقيه تلتحم
بالثوره السوريه لان في هاتين الثورتين
خلاص للمنطقه باختصار الثوره السوريه خاصه
بسوريا احنا ما ندخل دستور ما يسمحلنا اما
داخل العراق سيسقط ها اللعبه ابناء
الانبار وانتظر سيسقط ابناء ها
اللعبه يقوللك العراقيين خلو الزمره تتحكم
بمصيرهم بوحده بلدهم
اشكرك اخر جمله كيف ترد على هذا الكلام
اذا لم يستجب
المالكه المطالب فهذه الثوره
سقه الخرا
دقيقه بس دقيقه اخر سؤال اخر سؤال اخر
سؤال
هرون عن سوريا عن سوريا يقوللك يق لك على
التحام الثورتين التحام ماذا تقول لذ
الوده الع موي هكو التزي هكت موجه التز
الله الع ه صرت مشروع تركي صرت مشروع قطري
صرت مشروع
سعودي سوريا والعراق وحده واحده كانت
ستبقى ثورتان ستنطلق نحو اهدافهم المشركه
في اسقاط حكومه نوري الماركي في العراق
وبشار الاسد في سوريا والله عشم ابليس
بالجنه عشم ابليس
بالجنه الى
الل يعطيكم
[موسيقى]
العافيه